la journée était belle à au djibougumu
un matin frais qui rappelle que
l'automne est précoce au 50e parallèle
le village fondé il y a 30 ans et le
plus récent des neuf villages cris du
Nord du Québec il y a 4 ans ici 42
résidents avaient voté aux élections
provinciales soit 9% seulement des
électeurs inscrits traditionnellement à
l'automne
l'écrit de la dioschi sont en forêt à la
chasse à l'orignal les cris ont aussi
leur propre gouvernement régional
rappelle Jonathan saganache mais il ira
voter le 3 octobre les besoins sont trop
nombreux
au village son entreprise construit un
centre de formation professionnelle ou
des métiers comme la charpenterie seront
enseignées dans ankava 45% de la
population n'a aucun diplôme ça va aider
au développement de la communauté
directement aussi souvent les gens vont
à l'extérieur vont revenir parce que
justement dû au manque de maison
la pénurie de logements est un autre
problème dans les communautés crient et
Inuits bougumu des familles sont sur une
liste d'attentes depuis des années
aujourd'hui tu vois des familles qui
vivent encore trois quatre familles dans
la même maison puis on peut on va
essayer de régler cette situation on est
en crise seul candidate à avoir quelques
pancartes au village Maïté la break
saganache de Québec solidaire promet
d'agir on prévoit mille logements pour
le pour le Nord active au sein de
plusieurs organismes locaux et filles de
l'ancien député fédéral remet au SAG
elle espère devenir la première femme
autochtone élue à l'Assemblée nationale
pour moi c'est important de faire
campagne où ce qu'on fait ou ce que les
candidats font jamais campagne en fait
soit dans les communautés est-ce que la
clé de votre victoire serait là je pense
que oui
le kakiste Denis Lamotte avait été élu
par 46 voix seulement dans hangar va en
2018 devant le Parti québécois c'est en
majorité la population des villes de
chibougamo et de chapey qui avait voté
pour lui et qui pourrait bien le faire
et lire le gouvernement présent faire
mon affaire
la crise de la façon que ça devait être
géré vraiment au niveau des
infrastructures que ça soit scolaire et
sportif que soyez-nous avec que ce soit
sur le territoire acquérir je pense que
notre biling est bon sa priorité si il
est élu attiré plus de résidents il y a
des endroits stratégiques puisque des
emplois avec Hydro-Québec les mines on
aimerait nous autres que les gens
viennent s'installer chez nous qui
demeure chez nous
mais chez les Premières nations la CAQ
ne semble pas favorite à Ouji bougumu
cette promesse de François Legault a été
mal accueilli
je vais demander à Hydro-Québec regarder
la possibilité de construire des
nouveaux barrages on a pas de
consultation on n'a pas été ça a été mal
reçu ben moi je l'ai vu comme un
musée du village qui a gagné un prix
pour son architecture on rencontre Cathy
chez Capiaux la directrice à propos des
barrages elle cite un aînée de la
communauté la terre c'est comme le corps
humain tu affecte
nécessairement impact toutes les
systèmes autre frustration cette
question récurrente du racisme
systémique que la CAQ ne reconnaît pas
de dire ça pour moi c'est de me faire
dire que les expériences que j'ai vécues
le profilage me faire arrêter dans la
rue et du rouge
par un système d'éducation qui a appris
à ces gens-là à nous parler comme ça
comme si on était moins que humain
ça il y a du travail à faire là-dessus
le candidat libéral est Inouk et a été
maire de coup de joie pendant 6 ans les
14 communautés du nous navigue sont
accessibles par avion seulement la
sécurité alimentaire de son peuple est
une priorité
est énorme ça peut coûter 2 3 fois plus
cher que de vivre dans le sud mais avec
le taux d'inflation qui qui complique
notre qualité de vie c'est encore
beaucoup plus difficile et dans le Grand
Nord aussi la promesse de nouveau
barrage semble mal reçu non on en veut
pas ça c'est sûr et certain
Inuit écrit auront donc un gros rôle à
jouer dans les résultats de Gava mais
votre ont-ils
les émissions radiophoniques de Clarins
Snowboy sont diffusés dans tous les
villages crient
personne ne me parle des élections
dit-il je n'ai même pas eu de question
sur les dates du vote je trouve que
malheureuse
les Premières nations encore une fois
ont été quasi absentes des discours des
chefs ils veulent ils ont développé le
nom et nous vivons dans notre Québec
la circonscription dongava couvre
pourtant la moitié de la superficie de
toute la province
[Musique]